Huh? She's Somali. She's from Somali.
>> Yeah. Huh? She's 17. She turned 18 right
now.
>> She turn 18 next year. I'm interrupting.
Are you married?
>> Me?
>> No, I'm not married. Are you married?
>> I get your number.
>> My number.
>> Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have.
Case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when his sword is taken away, Allah says
he's going to say what? Send me back to
do Hajj, umrahra, salah, fasting, what?
No. Sodaka brothers and sisters is
getting thousands of shahadas monthly
yearly. Hundreds of thousands of people
are coming to Islam. They are printing
Quran, distributing material, training
duat. Brothers and sisters, do you want
the part of that goes on forever. This
is how Islam has spread around the
world. Brothers and sisters, carry on
this legacy of the prophetam inshallah
by donating whatever amount inshallah
and ayra right now inshallah. Enjoy the
video
brothers and sisters and dear friends. I
hope you guys are going in. So, I came
across a video and you guys know I am
the reaction video man and subhan Allah
when I saw this video brother and
sisters it really got me angry. It
actually got me so angry that I actually
even forgot that I commented in this
video about two week two months ago. I
think over two and a half months ago.
Subhan Allah. So, we're going to watch
the video guys and I want you guys to be
consistent because at the end of the
day, guys, I've been talking about this
for 13 years. Okay. Um and the double
standards and hypocrisy we have within
our community. When a sister does
something, her head showing whatever it
is, we all we go crazy. Yes. Okay. And
certain brothers, I'm not going to call
them D. Yes. certain brothers who are
doing Islamic Rams or whatever it is,
they go crazy when it comes to the
sisters. They do ais etc. But the moment
it's a brother, it's like nothing
happened. And this is not fair because
we are told in the Quran to speak the
truth even if it's against herself. If
you know you're going to watch for
yourself, just imagine for a second this
was sisters flirting, chatting,
freemixing with the opposite gender.
What would have happened? That would
have been an uproar. Well, let's watch
for ourselves and see if you have the
same reaction to brothers doing it in
thes. Yes. And they've even got a turban
on their head. Let's go straight to the
video. Here's the video.
>> Huh? She's Somali.
>> Somali?
>> Yeah. Huh? She's 17.
>> Oh, she turning 18 next year.
>> Are you married?
>> Me?
>> No, I'm not married. Are you married?
>> I get your number.
>> My number? Why are you trying to get
married?
>> Okay. First thing first, what I want to
say is first thing first here is that
the initial approach, you can't really
say there's nothing wrong. Yes. Um, and
there's nothing wrong with that. Do you
get what I'm trying to say? Like in in a
way where you do manners and okay you're
going up and saying are you looking to
get married? It's a little bit absur
bizarre like it's a bit spontaneous in
the moment but you have to say okay you
know what at the end of the day there
are guys who come and just ask for your
number etc like his happy days. So at
least you can say the initial thing was
there but then he ru can I get your
number? Sorry you respect you know if
you're going to go to a sister which
again you have to be careful cuz that
sister can be married her brother can be
there you can you can go left real
quick. Do you get what I'm trying to
say? But if you're going to approach and
say, "Look, sister, I just happened to
see you and I just wondering my I have
no ill intentions, but I was just
wondering that I would like to get to
know you for marriage. Can I speak to
your father or your brother and ask the
permission if I can get to know for
marriage if you are interested?" Calm,
respectful, decent. Yes, brother. No,
brother. Thank you. Bye-bye. There's
nothing wrong with that. Islamically,
there is nothing wrong with that. Of
course, you need to weigh the pros and
cons of that sister might be married,
husband might come, they might be, you
know, your janaza, um the brothers might
there, etc. So, you have to be careful.
But to go there like I want your number.
I want to get married. Bro, that doesn't
look serious to me, bro. With all due
respect, and you're in a bro, you're in
a sham. You're wearing a phobe. Yes,
you're wearing a phobe. You're
representing Islam, bro. Like the hijabi
system that represent Islam. You're
representing Islam, bro. Let's carry on.
>> Oh, what's your name?
>> J.
>> Jonathan.
>> Joffrey.
>> Jonathan. Joffrey.
>> Oh, okay. Um, are you from here?
>> Really?
>> Where?
>> West.
>> When you trying to get her into guns?
>> You serious? Or you playing? You
playing? I'm not playing. I'm not. You
want to get We should get an done,
right? You don't think is Is this the
imam?
>> So number two, obviously this woman is
entertaining. We don't know if she's a
Muslim or not a Muslim, but you can see
she's familiar with the terminology
Islamically. Ian, etc. I don't know if
she's got before. She knows what it is.
She's a Muslim from a Muslim background.
We don't know. But you can see she's
entertaining it. So they're as both as
bad as each other in that sense. We
don't know if she's a Muslim. She's not
a Muslim. You can't even say she's bad
because brother that's that's the life
she's about. With all due respect,
that's her life. But do you get it? You
should know better. And if you acted in
a conduct yourself in a better manner,
not even go and do that, she would not
go on that because she she's basically
on your level now. She's in your
frequency, bro. Okay. She's on your
frequency because you're coming in a way
that you can't clearly say it is
advised. I don't know if you can say
it's haram. Yes. Okay. There is some
kind of free mixing involved. There is
you approaching that in a not right
manner. So she's she's just matching
your energy, bro. And that energy is
there. As you can see, she's from a jah
background. Uh from what I went to
account, obviously um just to see who
this person is, etc. And she doesn't
look like she's practicing. She doesn't
look like she's a Muslim. I don't know.
So yeah, let's carry on. I hope you guys
enjoy the video, guys. But before that,
please download the Salah Pro app,
brothers and sisters. We are a charity.
All of our services on the app is for
free. Free kibla finder. No ads, free
salah reminders, encourages to pray,
tells you salah times. You can book a
salah instructor, a Quran instructor.
You can order a guided prayer map for
absolutely free if you want to learn how
to pray salah. Videos on how to pray
salah, salah hubs, and many, many more
brother sisters. We are not an app that
shares your information with third
parties. All of our services on the app
is for free. Download it now. Inshallah
and enjoy, guys. Let's go back to the
video.
>> We got im he's not the imam.
>> I got we got one.
>> This is major major major major alarm
bells. Any sister that is approached by
a brother and he says, "Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I've got I've got an imam or I
know somebody who can do an Listen,
listen, sister, listen. Not run for your
life. Do a U-turn and go the opposite
direction in the country. leave the
country. Any brother that comes to you
and approaches you and this that and
I've forgotten I imam and we can do this
or over zoom and this that red listen
bells forget the red flag this man is a
red flag he's a red flag there is no red
flags he himself is a red flag okay
actually forget red flag he's a black
flag okay so subhan allah you can see it
is alarm bells all over we know an imam
this is the greatest technique and tools
that is used by so-called religious
brothers I'll just put it like this from
the outward opinion okay may Allah
forgive these brothers I'm not trying to
belittle them etc I just believe it was
wrong the way it's conducted itself and
they use this okay and they do temporary
nikas yes okay for a couple of days or
whatever it is with the intentions no no
no no like and scholars even say this is
not permissible it is haram it doesn't
invalidate the nika but you are sinning
so be very very careful
>> yeah mhm how old are you
>> 21 okay I'm lowkey older than you so I
don't know if I can give you my number
>> I'm older than you mean though
>> I can give you like my snap and maybe
your
Um, she's 17.
>> Your thumb.
>> Did you get it from here or
>> Oh, where I got it from?
>> You don't know where you got it from?
>> You see how she already notices your
dress sense. Do you know what I'm trying
to say? He knows like, you know, maybe
she sent him. Yeah, your phobe. You
know, maybe look at you need to
understand. Look, find out there's
expectations that come with a uniform.
It's not easy. It's not easy for the
sisters. It's not easy for the brothers.
But there's expectations that comes with
it. And uh Dave Chappelle put it really
funny. You know, I think it was Dave
Chappelle. He was making a comedy
sketch, etc. I watched it a long time
ago before I came to Islam where he says
you know um imagine people come and say
oh just cuz I'm dressed up in a
miniskirt or dress it doesn't mean that
I am what you think I am like those
women who sell their stuff etc. He's
like yeah but and it's true like
obviously we can't judge it's very
important we judge from apparent meaning
a sisters dress up inappropriately or a
brother's doing inappropriate stuff
100%. However, to come and then judge
and say that woman sleeps around, it's a
major sin. You cannot say that. If you
see a brother has a earring and say,
"Oh, he probably drinks alcohol. That's
a major sin." You can't judge that deep.
Yes, you can judge as a parent. So,
here, subhan Allah, you can see that
he's saying, "Look, you know, Dave was
saying, imagine you're walking down the
road and there's someone in a police
officer uniform." Say, "Officer,
officer, I'm being robbed." And he said,
"Just cuz I'm dressed up in a police
officer uniform does not mean I'm a
police officer." You say, "What the hell
are you talking about? Why are you
confusing me?" There's expectations. So
the expectation she's having from you by
hinting at your phobe is you should
conduct yourself better and you should
know better.
>> H you got a sister?
>> No, I don't have a sister.
>> But if I had a sister, I would put her
on with you for sure.
>> Huh? East African. She's Somali.
>> She's
put on me. Look at that.
>> I'm not
She's 17.
>> No, she turning 18 next year.
That's all right.
>> She's young now.
>> Yeah, I texted you.
>> No, I ain't get it.
>> You said sup now.
>> No, she on ding.
>> You sure? You
>> said so long.
>> What I look like saying? She on de?
>> Yeah. You don't see her.
>> Okay. We're going to first get food.
Okay.
>> So, in a nutshell, guys. Okay. Why am I
doing this? Brothers and sisters, at the
end of the day, like I said before, you
know, the way we conduct oursel and
Allahh tells us, you know, that the
prophet he had the best ofl and manners,
etc. We're not innocent. Anyone has a
sin, etc. But you need to understand
that you are wearing the the religious
uniform that people can identify with
Islam that comes with responsibility.
Brother, I don't dress up in that
there's anything wrong with I would love
to. It's the most comfest thing ever.
For private personal reason, I don't.
However, me even having this beard is an
ama. the way I carry and conduct myself
is an ama. Do you get what I'm trying to
say? And we need to understand that we
represent Islam. So sisters and
brothers, when you're out there and
you're having that hijab on, you know,
it's it's heartbreaking when we hear
stuff like, "Oh, there's a brother."
Yeah. Or there's a guy that I'm getting
to know and then you see him a phobe,
etc. Or a sister, you got some kafid guy
saying, "Oh, yeah. Yeah, I'm I'm meeting
with this girl. She's a hijabi z or a
khabi." Yes. You need to understand that
uniform has weight to it. And understand
that weight. It's not easy. Don't make
it as an excuse of, "Okay, if I'm going
to be judge, I might as not wear it."
No. Try your best, but there's certain
things that you don't do. Like, for
example, if you're in a hijab and you
are kissing a guy on the road, that's
not acceptable. If you're a brother
who's wearing a phobe, who has a shama
on wherever, and you are, I don't know,
selling drugs or drinking alcohol or
stabbing people, whatever, habib, what
are you doing? So, the thing is that
brothers and sisters, we need to
understand it is an ama and we need to
understand that responsibility. Yes,
it's not easy, but Jenna has a price. It
has a price and if you are wearing those
things just to look righteous or ped
Allah will humiliate you. I believe this
here was I don't even know if the she's
recording. I think she might have those
glasses on maybe if I'm if I'm not
mistaken. Yeah, she had those class.
Maybe they didn't even know they were
being recorded. So look how embarrassing
and look at how Allah subhana wa ta'ala
made that public. Isn't that
embarrassing? Isn't that shameful? And
again I'm not trying to have a go at the
brothers and make them feel like you
know rubbish about theirel but the way
you conduct yourself. I'm so sorry with
all due respect. This is not something
when it comes to sisters one single hair
strand shows and you lose your mind.
Yeah. What about you? What about the way
you're conducting yourself? Subhan
Allah. And I've talked about this years
on end. Subhan Allah. So all I want to
do is bring you to this attention,
brothers and sisters, that let's be
careful. Let's conduct ourselves in the
best way possible, inshallah. And know
that the way you appear is a religious
symbol. And people look at you. Actions
speak louder than words, guys. Subhan
Allah. Let's be careful. Be mindful
inshallah. And allow our conduct, the
way we carry ourselves, how we dress be
a positive da than a negative one.
That's all I wanted to say. Inshallah.
May Allah bless and preserve you guys.
Till next time.